more than 800 000 illegals crossing the
southern border since october
but if the byte administration ends
title 42 dhs says we could see 18 000
migrants illegals per day
our next guest says biden is creating
the worst illegal immigrant crisis ever
in a fox news dot com opinion piece here
with more is co-host of the clay travis
and buck sexton show our friend
bucksacks and bucks thanks for being
here um when you
at one moment you think how can it get
worse but you're previewing that very
very soon and intentionally it could get
a lot worse
well pete that's absolutely the case i
was speaking to contacts at border
patrol this week
and they're
in essentially a state of what do they
expect us to do i mean what do they
think is going to happen
when you have about a 5 000 person
capacity per day for apprehensions
they'll call them encounters sometimes
at the southern border those are illegal
migrants coming in the number's already
about 8 000 on average across the border
and expectations based on existing
migrant flows and
what they're hearing on the other side
of the border is that as soon as title
42 goes you're looking at upwards of 18
000 migrants a day crossing the border
some are even saying that within the
first six to eight weeks after title 42
goes you could have a million illegal
immigrants in about a two-month period
let's call it crossing the border these
are unprecedented numbers last year was
probably the highest level of illegal
immigrant crossings we've ever seen it
depends on how you calculated it was
upwards of 2 million plus hundreds of
thousands of got aways the got away
number pete is also an estimate because
there are sometimes they know they don't
even have the personnel to calculate
properly that number and the buy
administration response to this is
essentially let it ride they're going to
move more people to the border to
process the illegals more quickly more
expeditiously so the american people
don't actually see what's really going
on that's it it feels like the thing
that the white house is most concerned
about are cameras on the border actually
because they want it to be as invisible
and as seamless as possible the concern
is not about stopping it it's about
not allowing it to be seen
yeah this is all about controlling the
political optics in an election year
because if they actually wanted to stop
the illegal immigration that's going on
or even lessen it at some level which is
really more realistic i suppose they
would change the incentive structure
essentially they'd make it less likely
that people who break our immigration
laws would be able to stay they do the
exact opposite at every turn we've known
that from the beginning of the bite
administration until the incentives
change they're just going to have more
and more illegal immigrants coming into
the country they know that the problem
for them is the american people aren't
with them so what they don't want is 15
or 20 000 people all at once camped out
of the border as we saw months ago and i
remember fox was doing great coverage of
that at the time so they want to make
sure that the people who come get in
quickly there's not a lot of crowding at
the border and if that means they
disperse them more readily in the
interior that's going to be the plan
to more efficiently distribute them
across the country while making sure
they have phones uh so that they can
maybe contact them this while it's good
to see the root causes have been
addressed i know it's sarcasm but it's
true that was their plan root causes and
and kamala harris was going to get on it
and it it seems none of that has
occurred uh buck sexton thank you so
much as always great op-ed check it out
at foxnews.com
thanks pete good to see you